jealousy ego and not knowing what a
wolverine is these actors turned down
movie parts for some peculiar reasons
in November of 2021 Fast and Furious
veteran Vin Diesel took to Instagram to
plead with Dwayne Johnson to participate
in the 10th installment of the
long-running franchise fast 10. Johnson
had previously stated that he would not
be returning which many believe is due
to a feud between the actors that has
spanned more than six years and counting
however diesel still tried to seemingly
guilt-trip the actor in front of his 82
million followers on social media
claiming that his children still refer
to Johnson as uncle Dwayne and that
Johnson's character of Lou Cobbs could
never be recast or replaced not long
afterward Johnson sat down with CNN and
set the record straight The Rock told
the world that he and Diesel had come to
an agreement in private long story short
the former wrestler would not be
returning to the franchise your mistake
is thinking you've got a goddamn Choice
boy
Johnson said that he was very surprised
by Diesel's Instagram post expressing
his disappointment in the actor's clear
manipulation he continued I didn't like
that he brought up his children in the
post as well as Paul Walker's death
leave them out of it it's safe to say
that Diesel's impassioned request didn't
make much of a difference in Johnson's
decision despite his frustration at the
very public way that it was handled
Johnson maintains that he will always
cheer for the success of the Fast and
Furious movies and their cast
A League of Their Own is a fictionalized
portrayal of the All-American Girls
Professional Baseball league and its
best team the Rockford peaches Deborah
Winger was originally cast in the lead
role and she spent months training with
the Chicago Cubs in order to increase
her authenticity however the moment that
Madonna was added to the project the
terms of endearment actress was out the
door Winger believed that rather than A
League of Their Own being the
historically empowering story it was
meant to be the queen of cops
involvement would drive the film in a
different direction she told the
telegraph I think her acting career has
spoken for itself and what am I supposed
to do huh
go back to taxi dancing
10 cents or some slop can sweat gin all
over me despite the film's eventual
positive reception the actress had a few
Choice words to say about the final
product like her claim that Madonna
lacked the proper preparation Winger
told Vanity Fair as entertaining as the
final film was you don't walk away going
wow those women did that you kind of go
is that true
in 2013 production for the Natalie
Portman Western film Jane got a gun was
about to kick off when it hit a major
snag after a three-day standoff over
delays and control of the final cut with
producer Scott steindorf director Lynn
Ramsey stepped away from the project the
day the production was supposed to begin
leaving a chaotic environment behind
Ramsay's choice to quit the film
ultimately led to the departure of
cinematographer Darius kanji an actor
Jude Law who was originally set to play
the movie's antagonist several unnamed
sources claimed that law had admitted to
only signing up for the project for the
opportunity to work alongside Ramsey
although he hasn't confirmed this
himself regardless without her in the
director's chair he seemingly had no
interest in continuing with the project
law was later replaced by Bradley Cooper
who also ended up dropping out due to
scheduling conflicts the movie would
finally hit theaters with Ewan McGregor
in the villainous role and Gavin
O'Connor in the director's chair
partially as a result of the casting
crew controversy Jane got a gun was a
box office flop today it's primarily
remembered as a low point for the
production company that financed it
Steve McQueen spent the 60s and 70s
enjoying the fruits of stardom appearing
as the leading man in countless films
that would go on to become Classics over
three decades after his death McQueen
still holds the moniker of the king of
cool thanks to his long list of
interesting hobbies and talents during
casting for the Western classic Butch
Cassidy and the Sundance Kid McQueen
accepted the role of Sundance after
reading through the script however he
wound up stepping away from the role
over disagreements with his co-star Paul
Newman McQueen's undeniable star power
led him to refuse second billing to
another actor despite the fact that
Newman was arguably more famous at the
time the role later went to Robert
Redford in what has become one of his
career defining performances Butch
Cassidy and the Sundance Kid went on to
Garner widespread a claim soaring to the
top of the charts as the biggest box
office draw for two weeks after its
release
in 2019 Charlize Theron sat down with
Andy Cohen on Watch What Happens Live
and discuss the topic of ageism in
Hollywood when Theron was asked by a fan
why she reportedly turned down the
Monumental role of Wonder Woman the Mad
Max Fury Road Star set the record
straight by sharing the real story
Theron explained that she was discussing
possible involvement in the film when
someone informed her that she would
actually be taking on a supporting role
I'm not familiar with it I don't really
know what it like I mean who what is
Wonder Woman do and my this person said
no it's for Wonder Woman's mom Theron
naturally turned down the role and seems
to be able to laugh about it now she
called it a defining moment in her
Hollywood career in which she had
crossed over to a completely new
category of roles without even realizing
it
foreign
you might remember jaw rule from his
hip-hop Heyday in the 2000s or maybe you
know him as the co-founder of the
disastrous fire Festival regardless in
the summer of 2002 Ja Rule was writing a
career high he was one of the biggest
rappers on the planet and secured that
Year's Billboard Award for top rap album
Ja Rule had a minor part in the Fast and
the Furious the first film in what would
become a massive franchise he was later
approached to be upgraded to a starring
role for the sequel Too Fast Too Furious
along with a cozy half a million dollar
payday surprisingly the rapper was
reluctant to participate in the film
rule allegedly acted like a bit of a
prima donna during the casting process
in 2015 two fast director John Singleton
explained that the rapper's ego had
become inflated elaborated he wouldn't
return calls I went to the studio to go
see him who was kinda playing me to the
side and I was like what what is this
when talking to MTV about the ordeal
rule pointed to his desire to make a
more serious name for himself in the
acting World saying I just felt it
wasn't the best move for me as far as
what I want to do in Hollywood right now
the frustrated director eventually
reached out to ludicrous to create a new
role in place of rules and the rest is
history
Brokeback Mountain the Western romantic
drama starring Heath Ledger and Jake
Gyllenhaal is a beautiful movie and it's
tough to imagine any other actors
portraying the cowboy lovers at its
Center however if you ask Mark Wahlberg
he'll tell you that he was considered
for one of the starring roles but wound
up turning it down in a 2007 interview
Wahlberg revealed his reasoning for
declining the role telling Premier
magazine I read 15 pages of the script
and got a little creeped out it was very
graphic descriptive the spitting on the
hand getting ready to do the thing it's
just not my deal Wahlberg may not be the
most reliable narrator after all he's
also claimed that he would have
single-handedly stopped 911. perhaps
he's telling the truth about having had
the opportunity to star in Ang Lee's
2005 classic but it wouldn't be the
first time Wahlberg has exaggerated a
little bit during a conversation with
the media many people point to Marky
Mark's strict Catholic beliefs as a
possible reason for his discomfort in
playing a man attracted to other men
Wahlberg has claimed that being a
Catholic is the most important aspect of
his life and his recent pivot to
faith-based Media like 2022's Father Stu
is further evidence of that the National
Enquirer even once reported that
Wahlberg's priest James Flavin always
has the final say in whether or not the
actor should accept a role an unnamed
Insider shared Wahlberg never makes a
final decision on a starring role until
father Flavin gives his okay Mark says
he owes his career to Father Flavin
seems that Wahlberg may not have made
the right call as far as money is
concerned the legendary performances of
Ledger and Gyllenhaal earned Brokeback
Mountain three Academy Awards and 178
million dollars at the box office
it's hard to imagine anyone other than
Hugh Jackman playing the mutant
Superhero Wolverine but Russell Crowe
almost took the role for himself Crow
was the first choice to play Logan in
2000's X-Men but the legendary actor
turned down the role over fears of being
Typecast what type was Crow worried
about being cast as why a wolf
Enthusiast of course given that Crow's
iconic character of Maximus in the film
Gladiator is associated with Wolves the
actor was concerned about becoming
Hollywood's go-to Mr Wolf according to
news.com.au he didn't seem to know or
care that Wolverines aren't Wolves at
all given the ongoing multi-billion
dollar franchise that was born from the
first X-Men film Crow losing out on the
role of a lifetime seems like a huge
misstep that could have led to years of
regret but in a 2019 interview on the
Howard Stern Show Crowe expressed his
respect for Jackman's performance and
showed that he had no hard feelings I
wouldn't have carried it through with
the Grace and the the direction that
Hugh gave it
and Crow who reckon
recommendably unknown actor at the time
to replace him in the role
Will Smith has appeared in his fair
share of headlines over the years
whether it's the Oscar slap heard round
the world or his complicated
relationship with his wife Jada the
actor is pretty familiar with being in
the spotlight back when prepping began
for Quentin Tarantino's 2012 film Django
Unchained Will Smith was offered the
opportunity to play the titular
character of Django which would
eventually go to Jamie Foxx in 2013
Smith sat down with Entertainment Weekly
and explained his choice to turn down
the role his explanation was short and
sweet Django wasn't the lead in Smith's
eyes King Schultz the dentist turned
Bounty Hunter played by Christoph Waltz
is the true lead of the film after all
Schultz gets to kill the bad guy however
in a much later 2016 Interview With The
Hollywood Reporter Smith claimed that he
turned down the role due to the
overwhelming use of violence in the
story he explained I wanted to make the
greatest love story that African
Americans had ever seen from American
Cinema essential actually Smith didn't
want to have to rely on violence as the
answer to racial conflict
[Music]